[Music]
hi my name is an Kil Hansen I'm director
general for DG communication of the
European commission I've been in this
job for now over three years uh and
before that I was uh a deputy secretary
General and also something we call Chief
uh Operating Officer uh taking care of
coordination of all the services and uh
policy coordination as well I've also
been Chief spokeswoman of the of the
commission for a while for a long while
actually uh and before that I was um
working in uh the services of a
commission different places on
competitiveness that's where I joined
originally and then I quickly moved on
to uh information communication and uh
culture so these are some of the things
that I've been doing during my career in
the in the European
Commission
in my current job uh I like that
communication is a kind of meeting place
where um all the policies of the
European commission and also politics uh
come together and of course uh that it's
about making sense of the European Union
for Europe's citizens that's really what
I like uh probably the most of course it
has to do about values also and a strong
sense of purpose communicating uh why
Europe is a good thing what it is for
and why it makes people's lives better
and where it makes sense uh for
Europeans to work together uh those are
some of the things that that that I
really like uh but it's also about
democracy yeah because uh in a healthy
democracy uh you need to inform people
you need to debate uh and you also need
to listen and in my job we also do a lot
of listening so that our policy makers
can take good decisions that uh uh make
a good difference for for Europe's
citizens so those are the reasons that I
really like my
[Music]
job I like a lot the openness that uh a
multicultural uh working environment
brings you know we are a diverse
organization we have 27 member states
and that gives a lot of of uh of
cultural uh mixes that are really
interesting it gives a broad Horizon so
uh you need to also have a lot of
listening capacities also there and
engagement and abilities to work uh
interculturally and since uh my
background uh was very much
Intercultural Communication in addition
to economics and uh a bit of political
science among other things that was a
bit my profile um I thought that was
really fitting for working in an
institution like the European commission
um and then I also like I have to say um
and it's linked to the purpose uh that
the European commission is uh very much
driving European cooperation uh and that
motivates a lot of the people working
here so working with a lot of motivated
people motivates me as
[Music]
well